- What's up, Believe Nation, it's Evan,
my one word is Believe,
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is that
if you see in you what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
I'm excited to launch
a new potential series,
this is the first in the series,
called EntRoundup, where the idea is,
so this is the concept,
we take a clip from different
entrepreneur-related channels,
channels that I look up to,
channels that inspire me,
some of the channels that
I'm paying attention to,
and take one of their clips that I think
is one of the best of from the past month,
and give you a snippet of it,
and mash them altogether,
and it's kind of the best of the month.
So if you're limited on time,
and you don't want to
watch everybody's channel
and everybody's video this
is kind of a sneak peak
into the world of a couple of awesome
entrepreneurial channels,
and hopefully get
inspired to make a change
in your business and in your life.
So I'm looking forward
to launching the series,
and hearing your thoughts.
(soft inspirational music)
- So this is strange for
me, I want to be real.
Anybody else been watching the Olympics,
especially track and field,
over the last like 20 or 30 years?
Who dominated in track and field?
- [Audience] USA.
Who? USA dominated.
You had Carl Lewis, Michael Johnson,
Michael Johnson came
with the gold shoes on.
Alright I'm just trying
to let you all know.
Ain't nobody else going to win the gold,
but the USA.
Kersee was there, they was murderin' them.
All of the sudden, something happened.
Hey look, you all think
I'm talking about him,
and I'm not.
I'm not dealing with him.
I'm telling you the environment you're in
is so important.
Look, this guy, this guy is
not only murdering the field,
but what happened was oh,
man, he murdered the field.
He don't compete, he dominates.
But what he did for Jamaica
was not bring a gold medal,
he brought a culture to Jamaica.
He didn't bring a
championship home, he brought
a culture home.
I got to help you all, let
me explain somethin' to ya'.
So you in America, and they're
sayin' to you that this
is his record, so theoretically,
you know how fast he is.
(applauds)
Come on, you hear me?
Theoretically, you know how fast he is.
So what you're doing
when you're practicing is
you're trying to beat
his time, theoretically.
I need you to hear what I'm saying.
This is why you need to
be in an environment,
because theoretically
they told you how quick
you needed to be and so
you'd race, and then you'd
look at the clock, and coach
would say "you missed it."
Alright, try again.
And you try again.
And you missed it.
But over in Jamaica, they
weren't racing against
a theoretical clock.
They, too, became gold
medalists and dominated,
because they was running
against the real thing
every single day.
Did you hear what I said?
They weren't running against the clock.
They weren't in their
minds saying okay, how fast
did I go?
They were running against
the fastest man in the world,
so they knew how fast they were going.
(audience laughing)
Listen to me.
And the reason why you are
not where you want to be,
you want to be a 10 and
you are running with sixes
every day.
You are hanging around fives every day.
The people you talk on the phone to, five,
and if you became a 10,
they'd hate you so much
that you afraid to be a 10
'cause you going to lose them.
You hanging around scrubs.
And when you start
winning, all you do is win.
And some of you are losers,
and all you need to do
is start hanging with some winners.
And then you're going to see
winning, and it's going to spill
over on you.
(soft inspirational music)
- Just spoke to the USC Football
Team and I said something
in there that really caught my attention.
I said something.
I'm sure you'll edit and
make it fly, because that's
how you do it, D-Rock.
For 80 or 90% of you, this
is going to be the best--
this is going to be as good as it gets.
This is the prime, this is the best.
And this rant is about timing.
You need to be aware of when
you have your big opportunities.
You need to squeeze so
f'ing hard when you've
got that moment.
You have to understand that
sh-- will always change.
If it's terrible right now,
it's going to get better.
If it is phenomenal right
now, it is going to get worse.
That is just the way it's always been.
I'm not smart, it's just f'ing history.
So please, if you take
anything out of this
mini little rant for
D-Rock, it's about timing.
Recognize your moments and strike.
That has absolutely been the foundation of
my success, whether it was
selling my baseball cards
when I just felt it, whether
it was the internet itself,
whether it was other things
like starting Vayner Media
when I had all these other
opportunities, but I wanted
to triple down on my strengths
during this golden era.
Sometimes they're fun,
sometimes they're taking a
step back, in theory, but
it's all about knowing
when to go all in.
And the one thing we get
is regret when we didn't
squeeze our best opportunity.
So when you're a football player at USC,
that is a big time f'ing
opportunity because most
of you don't go to the
League, and most of you
aren't successful in the
League, and this is your apex.
And whether you're a manager
in a store right now,
whether you're a great
student in high school,
whether you're awfully
pretty right now but you know
you're not going to be as pretty one day.
I'm being serious now.
I know this is silly sh--
but when you have your best
situation, when you have
the f'ing leverage, you
need to f'ing strike.
And when you don't, you don't
pout, you put in the work
to rebuild your next leverage.
I had YouTube, I had Twitter,
and when they weren't
as big anymore, I didn't cry
that Instagram or SnapChat
came, I put in the work
to build myself back up
and matter in that ecosystem.
And now that I've got the
Instagram moment again,
I'm pounding.
I'm pounding harder than
I did the last time,
'cause I learned, 'cause
from pattern recognition
from experience you get better.
And so if this can inspire
you, if you're sh--t's
good right now, quadruple
down, and if it's not,
stay quiet and build and
look for that moment when
you know it's good, pound.
Because squeezing when you have
the opportunity is the key.
(soft inspirational music)
- That's a characteristic
that I see in almost everybody
that I respect.
They all think that
everything they do sucks.
Or at least they have
very, very high standards
and are often disappointed
by their own work.
- Well, you know, I think
I have some of that,
but I also have that idea
of like, it's something
that my fa...
I don't know if I talked
about my dad with you.
But he was my wrestling
coach in high school.
He was also my Earth Science,
Biology and Environmental
Studies teacher.
- Really?
What a drag, you went to
school with your dad being
the tea...
That'd be f'ing hard.
(laughing)
- But I learned a lot
because he was no joke.
He didn't pull any punches
for me, he drove me
as hard if not harder
than his other students.
He didn't show any favoritism.
But one of the things
that was always his thing
on the mat, and I'm kind of paraphrasing,
but basically, you
either win or you learn.
Especially in that high
school/college setting.
You're learning about yourself.
If you went out there and you got your ass
handed to you, then you just
got beat and didn't learn
anything, well yeah, you're a f'ing loser.
You take the moment,
reflect on it, build on what
you did wrong, and now
you're actually in a way,
you've won.
Now you know more about
yourself, you know more about
your limitations or what you
need to improve or expand
your talents or your limitations.
So I guess whenever I'm
doing a thing, I'm always
looking at it from a learning perspective,
so there aren't necessarily
mistakes unless they're fatal,
and then you wouldn't
know anyway, so whatever.
- That really is the right
way to look at everything.
You win or you learn.
You have great experiences
because you were successful,
or you have very beneficial
experiences 'cause you realized
what went wrong, or what,
just one more wrinkle,
one more piece of information,
or one more experience
that you can add to your
database of knowledge,
and it'll make you better
at everything you do.
(soft inspirational music)
- [Passenger] How do you cope
working in an environment
where there is so much
malicious people and envy,
where only the powerful ones get a break
and the introverted are left out?
How do you cope working
in that environment?
- Hmm.
Well I'm not introverted,
so I don't have a problem
with that, but I think
in an environment where
there's a lot of...
- [Passenger] Malicious people and envy.
- Malicious people and envy.
I just try to stay in my
lane and focus as much
as I can on my vision.
Now sometimes I get off
track and I allow negative
conversations or comments to affect me.
And I'll talk about them,
I'll think about them,
for a couple of days, but
typically I'm pretty good
at being committed to my
vision, staying in my lane.
You know, my friend Chalene
Johnson, she always said
run your own race.
Don't try to run anyone
else's race, don't try to be
like anyone else, or feel
like you have to keep up
with other people.
And so I really just focus on my vision,
and being committed to that.
So that's what I try to focus on.
I remember early on, I got
in a, in probably 2009,
I got in a Twitter battle with this guy
that I'd never met, he
was another marketing
social media guy.
I think he might have
written a book or something.
He had a little bit of
credibility in the social media
space, and I remember he said
something that offended me,
and I started tweeting back.
And then he kind of fed
into my going back and forth
with him.
And we were like, for three
days, both reacting to
each other, calling each
other names, and I remember
some people were supportive
and jumping on with me,
and kind of going after him.
And at one point in day
two, someone was like,
you just need to let this go.
This is not, one, it
doesn't look good for you,
two it's a waste of your
time, and three, it's taking
you away from your vision.
And I remember early on just that lesson.
I can't remember who told
me that, but I remember
early on just being like,
yeah, this is not helpful
just to constantly
combat with other people
who are malicious or envious or attacking
in any way, so any time
I see negative comments
now, or anything that I
feel like could take me
off track, I just smile or
say "thanks for the feedback"
and keep focused.
And I think that's what you
should be focusing on is
staying committed to the vision,
and on running your own race.
(soft inspirational music)
- How do you stay motivated,
and how do you motivate people
when they start to slack?
- Now, motivation is
kind of a strange word,
because it doesn't really
mean what we think it means.
We think it means that we're
fired up to do something.
We think that it means
we're eager and passionate
to make something happen.
And we think that somehow
we should just be able
to turn on that eagerness
and turn on that passion.
But we can't.
'Cause you just can't turn
on passion, you can't just
turn on the desire to execute a task.
It just doesn't work that way.
And honestly that isn't
even what motivate means.
Motivate doesn't mean to yell and scream
and encourage.
No, to motivate actually
means to provide a motive,
a reason why.
So to motivate someone
is to explain to them why
they're doing what they're
doing, how it will help them,
where it'll take 'em.
Why they should continue
to work and to struggle
and to fight.
And when you need motivation yourself,
don't look for someone to scream and yell,
don't look for someone else
to give you motivation,
look at yourself.
Look at yourself, and remind yourself why.
Why you are doing what you are doing.
Remind yourself that this
struggle, this temporary pain,
this fight, this fight that
you're in, this is what
will make you stronger and
faster and smarter and better.
And then with that motivation,
go forward into the fray,
into the storm, into
the heat of the battle
where victory is forged.
(soft inspirational music)
- My intention in creating
Master Class came from
the understanding that
everybody's story is the same.
All stories are connected.
And there is nothing that
anyone who's living on Earth
has ever felt or known or
experienced on a soul level
that hasn't been felt
or known or experienced
by someone else.
One of the most difficult
things in life is feeling
that you are the only
one, you are the only one
who's traveled this path,
who's felt this way.
- I had nowhere to go, I
was homeless at the time,
I'd lost my family.
Next thing I know, I'm in
this car for three years,
man, I'm struggling.
- Who's experienced such
devastation or joy or triumph
or victory, so for me, I
define a master as someone
who has fully stepped in
and owned the full progress
and trajectory of their life.
- Persistence pays off.
That's lesson one.
- But hearing stories told
from the mouths of people
who know how to live, how
to course-correct, how to
keep going, how to never
quit, how to rejoice
in the good times, and
have faith in the bad,
those people are masters.
Anyone who can do that is a master.
And their ability to share
their stories only helps
the trajectory of others who listen.
(soft inspirational music)
- So the Instagram Live folks,
if you couldn't hear this,
he was asking about concert photography,
how do I get started?
How do I have a relationship
with these folks?
Start small.
But start.
Like, all this pontificating,
wondering, like, do you
have a camera?
Are you going to a show?
I don't care if you're buying
a ticket, a $9, $10 ticket
to go to the local show, you
need to start taking pictures,
because the area that you're
talking about working in
is very specialized,
it's hard to break into,
it's hard to make real money.
And I'm just setting
these things up for you,
this is the reality of this situation that
you're asking me to do.
I don't know if you want to make a living
and a life doing this stuff,
or if this is a hobby,
but it's very hard to
break into, and it's very
hard to make money.
I want that to cue one
of two things in you.
You either go well, I don't
give a sh--, this is the thing
I'm doing.
I want to do this more than anything,
and I'm going to do what it takes.
And if it's hard, that's
awesome, because there's
going to be less competition.
Thing two would be like,
oh my God, Chase says it's
hard to make money and break
in, I don't want to do that.
If Chase says it's hard, it's really hard.
Great, then don't do something...
Go do something else because
you didn't really want it
bad enough.
Let's pretend you're in the first camp.
You want it.
You're like I don't care,
I'm going to do this.
This is my calling in life.
If that's the case, start small.
Start taking pictures, buy the $10 ticket,
work your ass to the front
of the row, the thing,
you're getting smashed in,
you're taking those photographs.
What can you do to a,
get great at your craft,
b, go there all the time.
Not just on the Friday
and Saturday night shows,
shoot all of the shows,
because you got to put in time
to master your craft.
If you're just another
sort of low to medium level
concert photographer, no
money, no game, it's not
going to happen for you.
It might be fun, and you
might be able to get a couple
of free shows out of the
deal, but I'm not assuming
that that's your goal.
I'm assuming that you want to be the best.
And I could be wrong, so take
this with a grain of salt.
But if you want to be
the best, you have to...
How are you then so known that
the first club that you...
Do you know the owners, do
you know the sound guys,
do you know the bands that are coming?
How into it are you?
Are you doing the other 50%?
This fricking thing comes
up in every single episode,
this video that I put
out called The Other 50%.
You should watch that.
Are you doing the other 50%?
Then, go beyond that one club.
Are you the guy who's known,
like, oh man, I got...
The Pixies are comin', I
want Xavier to shoot it.
You have to become that guy.
And the way you do it is
you're there all the time.
Just showing up, you've
heard that just showing up
is half the game.
You have to have talent,
you have to be skilled,
you have to have all those
things, but just being
so relentless with your
pursuit of the thing
is incredible.
(soft inspirational music)
- I am the king!
I will punish you.
- Any man who must say "I am
the king" is no true king.
- [Charlie] This is the
most important sentence
that Tywin ever says.
According to Tywin, power
does not come from telling
other people that you have it,
it comes from showing them.
Tywin does that in many
ways, and I want to start
with some of the
sub-communications of power,
meaning the things that
Tywin does with his
body language and his voice.
And I have to give Charles
Dance here, massive amounts
of credit, because he did
a phenomenal job of acting
these scenes out.
So let's explore how Tywin
enters crowded conversations,
first off, with a boom.
- I'm told we still have his sisters.
- The first order of business
is ransoming Sir Jaime.
- [Council Member] No truces,
we can't afford to look weak.
- [Council Member] We should
march on them at once.
- [Council Member] First, we
must return to Casterly Rock
to raise more...
- They have my son!
- [Charlie] Now you may
struggle to be heard when
there's a lot of people
speaking, many of us do.
You might stop and start,
try to find your way in
politely and ultimately
not get listened to at all.
But not Tywin.
He startles people by going
from silent to booming
in an instant.
That grabs attention immediately.
But what's interesting is
that he often doesn't stay
booming for too long.
Once he has attention, he
quiets right back down.
This makes his quiet mode
of interaction just as
frightening as his booming
tone, because you never know
when he's going to switch.
- They have my son!
Get out, all of you.
- [Charlie] You don't need
to scream like Tywin does,
but the lesson of entering
with a slightly louder
and deeper tone is one
that applies just as well
to modern-day interactions.
Pay attention to any group
and you'll see that the
person who is listened to
when there's a lot of people
trying to speak is often
the loudest when entering.
Don't stay loud forever,
though, if you're going to
use this small piece of advice,
because that can just be obnoxious.
You may also have noticed
that Tywin is very comfortable
with silence.
This is a power move that I
discussed in another video,
so I won't spend too long on
it, and I'll link to it here
if you want to click the little
white button in the corner,
but Tywin likes to use
silence right after people
have said something to provoke him.
It gives them a few extra
seconds to regret their
decision to stand up to
him, and to sit in fear of
what he might do next.
- My father won the real war.
He killed Prince Rhaegar,
he took the crown,
while you hid under Casterly Rock.
- The king is tired,
see him to his chambers.
- [Charlie] The silence
that Tywin makes creates
a staredown like you might see for boxing
or UFC promotions.
The first person to
flinch or look away loses,
which is why fighters
go to such great lengths
to not give an inch of ground.
And this isn't just an
arbitrary rule that was
made up for boxing.
Flinching and breaking
eye contact are built in
evolutionary tells that communicate fear,
which is why they can
sometimes matter even more
than raw strength when it
comes to a confrontation.
Because when one animal
isn't afraid, that's a good
sign that it has an advantage
that needs to be respected.
Just watch this charging
gorilla back off when a
puny little human doesn't
flinch, even though the
gorilla could obviously
tear him limb from limb.
- [Man] He charged and
charged and charged again,
and I think, and I'm sure, if I would have
even flinched once....
- [Charlie] But Tywin's
subcommunications of power
go beyond the ape realm.
His word choice is a distinctly
human way of using power.
He doesn't ask people
what to do or make threats
by saying if you do this,
then I'm going to respond
like this.
He tells people what they
are going to do, using the
word will.
It conveys absolutely
certainty that they will do
as they are told, and
again, the certainty that
Tywin will be listened
to adds to the sense
that he should be listened to.
(soft inspirational music)
- Taking action is a cure-all.
Taking action solves all
the problems that you're
going through.
Whatever problem you have,
whatever thing is in front
of you, whatever obstacle
is there that seems
unsurmountable, it's not
going to get fixed by just
sitting and complaining
and wallowing and feeling
sorry for yourself.
It happens from taking action.
As soon as you can move
from that place of being
unhappy and desperate,
and sorry for yourself to
how do I solve this?
Who do I need to contact to help me?
How can I use the resources
I have to fix this?
As soon as you start moving to that land,
that's when you start to make progress.
Taking action is the cure-all.
And this is what happens so
many times to entrepreneurs,
not even just with problems
but with ideas in general.
How often do you get an
idea for something that
you want to do, and then
you say tomorrow I'm
going to do it, and then tomorrow
comes and you don't do it?
How many times?
That happens over and over
and over and over and again.
It's a human condition,
it's not just entrepreneurs.
We have these things, these
ambitions, these drives
that we set for ourselves
and then we don't follow
through on.
The best way to start
on that idea you have
is to take action.
Do something immediately.
As soon as you set a goal, I want to
start a YouTube channel.
Great.
What are you going to do
on your YouTube channel?
I want to interview people.
Amazing.
Today, set up your YouTube channel,
and send out 10 emails
to people to ask them
for interviews.
People that you know, people
that you think will say yes.
When you commit to somebody
else, you're much more
likely to follow through.
And what happens is,
perfection becomes the enemy
of action.
You want to make it perfect,
and because you make it
perfect, it gets more, more,
more, more, more complex
and complexion is the enemy of execution,
because you build it up to this big thing,
this big scary thing
that has to be perfect,
you don't do anything.
Before I set up my YouTube
channel, I need to have
the perfect channel art,
or I need to have the
right thumbnails, and I
need to know what my script
is going to be, and I need
to know my intro and opener
and I need the gear, and
all of these things that
you need to have to make a perfect video.
And because it becomes this big thing,
you don't do anything about it.
And then the next day you
wake up, and it's gone, poof.
As soon as you set a goal for yourself,
I want to go and do this,
the best next thing you can do is
take some form of immediate action,
and ideally, commit to somebody else,
whether it's a friend,
whether it's a potential
customer, whether you're
sending emails out,
whether it's your family,
whether it's a neighbor,
commit to somebody else,
because when you do that,
you're much more likely to follow through,
because you won't let them down.
You'll let yourself down all the time.
You let yourself down
every morning when you wake
up and hit the snooze button.
You're letting yourself down.
The first thing you do in the
morning is let yourself down.
You set a goal, boom, I let myself down.
You let yourself down all the time.
But you won't let other
people down nearly as much.
So take immediate action,
and then follow through
with somebody else, so that you don't let
yourself and them down.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video,
was there a lesson that
really rung true for you
that you're going to
apply immediately somehow
to your business or your life?
Leave that down in the comments.
Really excited to see
what you have to say.
Also, should this series continue?
This is a test series,
this is the first edition.
There might be a volume two,
there might be volume three,
or we might just kill it
altogether based on the
results, what you guys have
to say, so let me know.
If you have suggestions,
leave it down below as well.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.